[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
it wasn't until you came into the
picture that the narrative changed
a convicted killer released after a
battle at the parole board what life
will look like after prison for an 87
year old man and
a wisconsin man says it was self-defense
but the jury says otherwise
joshua w aide guilty of
first-reintentional homicide
he didn't say it he told my mom he
called her earlier that night said
as soon as i walked in he was going to
shoot me admitting to murder
but an ohio man says the reason he
dismembered his roommate
is not what the prosecution makes it out
to be plus a big tech founder is going
to write a big check
amid his split with his wife of 27 years
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin an 87 year old man convicted of
killing his wife in california
is now free law and crimes anjanet levy
is here to explain the strange
circumstances
over his legal battle to win release and
how law and crime may have helped
brian we've been following william
bradford's case now for a few months
twice in the past the port parole board
in california said that bradford was
suitable for release
and the governor reversed those
decisions until now
no one disputes william bradford shot
and killed the mother of his children
joan bradford in 1988.
los angeles county deputy district
attorney john lewin prosecuted bradford
in 2002
and won a conviction but the question
about whether bradford
actually threatened to kill lewin had
been a hotly contested issue
john lewin has been a thorn in my side
for the last three years
and there has been nothing more
satisfying
than to get this resolved bradford's
attorney maya amig has been fighting
back against lewin's claims that
bradford planned to kill him and his
family
for years lewin is a high-profile
prosecutor in los angeles county
who's made a career out of prosecuting
cold cases
he's prosecuting robert durst for the
murder of his close friend susan berman
when bradford went to prison in 2002 an
inmate came forward to report
bradford confessed to killing his wife
and also said that he wanted to kill
lewin but polygraph test results from
months later
showed that inmate recanted the claim
about bradford wanting to murder lewin
it wasn't until you came into the
picture that the narrative changed
law and crime confronted lewin about the
polygraph results in february
he realized his error and wrote a letter
to governor newsom
saying he no longer objected to
bradford's release and really had no
standing to do so
i just wanted to correct the record so
this isn't about um
you know my ego or his i was glad that
he
was able to write a letter that
effectuated
mr bradford's release
now william bradford we're told is in
some sort of transitional housing
that is appropriate for somebody of his
age who is suffering from dementia
the parole board had determined through
interviewing him and through some
other information that he was not a
threat to the general public
brian thanks aunt jeanette joining us
today is criminal defense attorney mike
corbonix and terry austin
mike this is a contested issue on one
hand he's guilty
no doubt of that but on the other he
served a long time
and he isn't a danger to anyone in what
looks like his final years
what do you think of his early release i
think it was the right thing to do in
this manner
in this matter dementia's horrible i
think it's
it's a better thing for the prison
system that he's in a more appropriate
area where they can deal with these
horrible mental health issues
so i think the parole board did the
right thing and i have to give the
prosecutor credit
by at finally informing the parole board
that he had no objection after the
proofs and i could understand his
position listen i'm a former prosecutor
defendant and you know i've been
threatened and
a former defendant threatens you you
take it seriously
absolutely now terry i can't be happier
about this because our very own
engine who's here with us uh helped to
make this happen by overcovering
by uncovering some confusion as to
whether or not there was a threat
what did you make of the governor not
stepping in to get involved here and
letting him get released
well first of all kudos to anjanette she
was able to
uncover the truth and i think that's
obviously fantastic
but you know at this point the governor
is doing the right thing
by not intervening with the parole
board's decision
if in fact that the parole board has
decided
he's not a threat to the public and if
in fact
he did not make this threat against any
attorney
then i think he should be released it
turns out that he's in this transitional
home
and you know in point of fact that's
probably the best thing for
everyone because if he in fact has
dementia this is probably the best help
he's going to get
exactly now anjanette the uncover of
truth what was
your sense about john lewin here
you know in talking with him and i and
it took a few days to kind of work
through this
i really got the impression that he
really believed
that william bradford had threatened him
and his family
and i went through the polygraph test
results with him the documents that
actually
came from his office and i said no i
think you really need to look at this
and i think it really stunned him and i
think he
he realized he made a mistake and he
corrected it as quickly as he could
uh really the tragedy here is the
bradford children they don't really have
a relationship with their father
and their mother is gone it's a horrible
thing and um
you know i just wish them the best and
i'm glad we could help tell the truth
here the truth and the facts are what
matter yeah antoinette we're so glad
that you know how to read a polygraph
test and we're able to
present that to lewin derek sherwin is
asking for a new trial as he awaits
sentencing for the murder
of george floyd law and crime is taking
a closer look at the trial that the
entire world watched
we'll take a look at the key moments
from the trial and what comes next
law and crime presents inside the trial
of derrick showman
airs friday night at 9 eastern 8 central
on the lawn crime network which will be
hosted by our own
angenette levy now to italy where two
american students have been sentenced to
life in prison for the death of a police
officer
a roman jury found finnegan elder and
gabriel natal hyorth
guilty of homicide extortion and other
crimes the two californians claim
they did not know mario cicelo rega was
an officer when elders stabbed him 11
times in 2019.
they claimed they acted in self-defense
during a struggle but reggae's partners
said they identified themselves as
police officers
natalya hearth hid the knife used in the
stabbing and an
italian court's accomplices can be
charged with murder
the 20 year old and 21 year old said
they were trying to get their money back
after a botched drug deal elder's father
yelled in the courtroom
finnegan i love you when the verdict was
read
and in florida police rescued a missing
95 year old woman
julia goodman went missing from her
walton county home in the early morning
last weekend as darkness fell deputy
craig yost found the 95 year old in the
woods
almost two miles from her home officers
can be seen comforting the woman
and wrapping her in blankets until
emergency services arrived
still ahead on law and crime daily a
titan of big tech and his wife
are calling it quits after 27 years of
marriage we'll tell you how much is at
stake
but first the verdict is in for a
wisconsin man accused of killing a man
and attempting to murder two others the
jury's decision when we come back
[Music]
guilty on all counts that's the verdict
for the trial
of wisconsin man after deliberating for
just one hour and 20 minutes
the jury find the defendant joshua w8
guilty of first-degree intentional
homicide
after three days of testimony a jury
found joshua aide guilty of murder for
the death of his ex-girlfriend's father
james by the defendant gruntner
guilty of attempted first reintentional
homicide the four-year-old was also
found guilty of two counts of attempted
murder
for shooting his ex-girlfriend rebecca
brokowski and a family friend john
miller
the state claimed ade wanted to get back
together with brokowski at the time of
the attack
you need to consider that all of these
victims were shot in the head
with a ruger pistol with a laser
he intended to kill them aide claimed
that he acted in self-defense
and that the three people he shot were
trying to kill him and the only thing
that fits the evidence
that makes any sense whatsoever is
joshua he
walked into an ambush and the only thing
that i stated in my opening statement
that joshua is guilty of is being
the survivor aid sentencing is set for
july 21st
back with us as criminal defense
attorney mike corobotonix and terry
austin
terry one hour and 20 minutes of
deliberation the ink on the verdict she
probably didn't even have time to dry
were you surprised at how quick this
verdict came well
i was not surprised that it was quick
but i have to admit i was surprised that
it was
that quick it's one of the fastest
verdicts that i've ever seen
but listen don't forget we had surviving
witnesses and their testimony
was really pivotal in this case the
father
you know obviously passed away but
rebecca the daughter
she testified and you could tell how
much
the jury might have been responding to
her because
she really was emotional even though she
didn't
technically break down in tears you
could tell she was holding it back
and john miller to the other individual
who was shot
you have to remember his testimony must
have impacted the jury as well
knowing that they saw what exactly
happened
and two people were testifying so i'm
not surprised that it was guilty i'm not
surprised it was fast i was just
surprised it was
that fast now mike you're a trial guy
you work with
juries uh as a prosecutor former
prosecutor and a defense attorney
what do you think the deliberation room
was like here and
what about the case really stuck out to
you
well i think that the this case was
so straightforward and the
the good thing about this case that made
it go so quickly
was the fact as terry pointed out is
this was very
civilian for lack of a term better term
driven
there were real people involved in this
so you really didn't have a defense of
law enforcement
messing up the investigation things of
that nature
and i think really brian we've talked
about this many times
when you put your client on the stand as
a defendant you're taking a huge risk
in this case though it seemed like the
evidence was so overwhelming
it couldn't get any worse so whether
you're found guilty in an hour and a
half or two or three days
you're still doing the same amount of
time exactly
coming up on law and crime daily a
reality star has been released on bail
after being arrested on child porn
charges plus
the trial of the dismembered roommate in
ohio will bring you the video where the
man on trial
admits to the murders
we're back and now to ohio where one
defendant is caught on camera admitting
to murdering his roommate
whose attorney says that's only half the
story
michael dixon is on trial for murdering
dismembering and then burning the
remains of his roommate
jim whittaker the 41 year old dixon
admitted to the murder but claims it was
in self-defense
it's clear all right no no all right i
want you
to hold i'm going to hold it again okay
so if i have it
is it just like this
okay and then what happened go ahead you
can grab it just kind of hold it
like that okay and it went off
on this side of his face okay did he die
instantly
dixon said his daughter melody sue was
in the bathroom at the time of the
shooting
but when the 19 year old was interviewed
by police she makes reference to
whitaker killing himself
we figured that he just you know left
don't say anything to anybody talk to
his friends and they said well
don't report him yet because he might
not want anyone to know
every moment
did he say anything i mean he
talked about killing himself oh he
talked about it but he never
said that often yeah
you to break down this ohio death and
dismemberment trials criminal defense
attorney
mike corobotix and co-host terry austin
terry
that what was that what we were
expecting uh dixon to say when he took
the stand
well you know i was expecting some type
of self-defense claim
or defense of others claim i mean what
else is he going to say
he has to defend his actions and i think
that's the only thing he could say
if in fact he truly feared that his
daughter's life was in danger then you
know under the law he has a right to try
to save her life
but the real question is here there's so
many inconsistencies and
whether the jury is going to believe
that or not i i think
it's going to be hard for them to accept
that as a real defense
yeah it seems like one too many
inconsistencies but maybe there's a
strategy here
mike word on the streets of new jersey
is that you are the top count killer is
that what the defense is doing here
admitting to the lesser accounts but
trying to beat the top count
i i think um i hope they're more
successful at it than i am at times
brian but uh
i think it sometimes there's a case
where you have nothing else to do
but just really be going to damage
control
and a lot of times that's what we need
to do in a case because we want to get
the
least sentence we can for our client and
you
can lose credibility with a jury if
sometimes in these situations you really
say
everything's wrong and basically you're
saying this never happened and please
forget about it
that's not going to happen so you've got
to see somewhere you can maintain your
credibility
and defend your client do you think they
maintain credibility here
by admitting to some and kind of pushing
back on other
uh facts or charges though mike um i
think they do as long as they're
consistent with it
and it fits the facts i mean it's always
a difficult road to to go down but
i think you need to do that and you need
to be consistent not just or when you
have that kind of theory
it has to be consistent you can't keep
changing and throw everything against
the wall
terry real quick what do you think about
that about trying to be consistent and
admitting to some but
pushing back on others is that a good
strategy for this type of case
usually it is but i don't think it was
here when the defense attorney was doing
his opening one of the things he said
was well the prosecution is claiming if
he's lying here he's lying there
and the first thing i thought about if i
had been a juror in that case was
well of course he's telling the truth
when he's talking about covering up the
bodies
because in fact you have the evidence
there so he has to admit that
but he's lying about these other things
like the defense
because he really has no defense and so
the first thing he said to the police
was
i don't know where he is so i think that
uh you know the jury is going to cipher
that out
yeah they might be able to see right
through that good point terry when we
come back
a big tech couple is headed for a big
split over 130 billion dollars hangs in
limbo
as a pair divvies up their assets
welcome back an olympic boxer has been
arrested for the kidnapping and murder
of his girlfriend
and her unborn child felix verdejo
sanchez was arrested in puerto rico
after authorities say he killed kishla
rodriguez ortiz and her unborn child
which she claimed was sanchez's police
say a witness told them sanchez punched
rodriguez ortiz
injected her with a syringe and then
they both tied her feet and arms with
wire
a complaint claimed sanchez and the
witness threw the woman into the san
jose lagoon
and sanchez fired shots at her rodriguez
ortiz's remains were found on saturday
and identify with dental records
the 2012 olympian named el demente or
the diamond
turned himself in the following day he's
being held without bail
until his trial now to arkansas
where josh duggar has been released on
bail after being arrested for possession
of child pornography
the 33 year old former star was released
into the custody of a friend
and will not be allowed to be alone with
his six children during duggard's
hearing special agent gerald faulkner
said some of the images found on the
suspect's computer were quote
in the top five of the worst of the
worst i've ever examined
this is not the first time the reality
tv personality has been accused of
possessing child pornography in 2015 he
was accused by five girls
of inappropriately touching them
including two of his younger sisters
jessa and jill duggar faces 20 years
behind bars on each charge if convicted
and up to a 500 000 fine
the world's richest couple is calling in
quids after more than 27 years of
marriage
terry austin has more i was a little bit
surprised um
as you point out they do seem unified
and and even now
continually they seem unified forbes
estimates bill gates is worth more than
124 billion dollars
we sat down with divorce attorney heidi
harris she breaks down how the couple's
assets could be divided
i'm not sure that it will necessarily be
a true 50 50 split you know when we look
at the case of
um you know the basos versus scott case
that wasn't a 50-50 split harris does
not believe the divorce will affect
microsoft and the bill and melinda gates
foundation
they seem to have a unified front
regarding the foundation's purpose and
all the good work that it does
so i i would once again take the
the way that they've handled this matter
so far as an example
of their ability to work collaboratively
according to reports the gates did not
sign a prenuptial agreement before they
married in 1997.
what harris is most impressed by is how
the details of the separation
have been kept out of the media to get
this done quietly
and and perceivably amicably regardless
of what went on it's a personal matter
and and they kept it that way and i
think that that's a wonderful thing for
everybody
let's bring into mike and terry one last
time mike seems like sparks won't fly
during this divorce
as there seems to be a separation
contract or a caprina between the gates
is that typical in these types of cases
i don't know i don't know many people
with 150 billion dollars brian so
yeah i mean this just seems so
you know fantasy like with all the money
involved but
i'm sure that this is pretty natural in
these
type of wealth divorces that
everything's laid out beforehand to
avoid anything
down the road and it looks like they did
we're successful according to this
lawyer
mike i'm surprised with a billion dollar
smile like yours i thought you know more
people like this but
let's go to terry terry they will remain
co-chairs and trustees of their
foundation
and committing to giving most of their
money away through philanthropy
could them working together after
divorce maybe make this process
easier or harder i think it's going to
be
easier working together remember they're
not only husband
and wife but they're also public figures
and they're accustomed to appearing in
public so
i think even if they have feelings
underneath they will be
able to come out in public and work
together
they also have a job to do i mean this
foundation is very
important to them they have a common
goal to make sure that the foundation is
successful
and probably the most important part
here is the fact that there is a
community they're trying to serve
they want to make sure that the
foundation has enough funding
to serve that community so they're going
to come out in public
and they're going to be i think as
amicable as possible i don't think
they're going to skip
a beat i think we're going to see the
exact same bill and melinda gates
that we saw in the past and just really
quickly terry do you think that this
comes from a lot of preparation
beforehand
we talked about the contents of that
contract in their in their marriage do
you think that's why it's going so
smoothly
absolutely i think this prenup helped i
think that was converted into this
contract they agreed on all of the terms
and they made sure they came out
remember they had this wonderful joint
statement the exact same wording so i
think it's going to be as smooth as
possible
well it's good to hear it mike terry
thank you for joining us and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you